I'm here with Stephen Jones, who's a senior software engineer at Nvidia.
Stephen, tell us about your job.
&gt;&gt; I am the CUDA lead at Nvidia, which means that I'm responsible for the
programming model and for the engineering which goes behind that.
So, when we look at the set of things we could do for CUDA, for example,
the list is long--50, 60 things that we could do.
We've got time for maybe 5 or 10 of them.
And so I sit and evaluate what we can do, what's useful to do, what's the right direction.
I'm not the only person who makes these decisions.
But I'm the engineering end of that.
So I, I sit there and figure out what the resources
are going to need to be, and what different groups we
have to pull together to make these things happen.